right we do something simple cool so I
think that won't stress you out and
something we've done quicker than order
to take away a very straightforward easy
Malaysian curry we're gonna make a curry
paste right okay the most exciting thing
about this pace is that you can make it
the start of the week yeah use a bit of
it and just keep in the fridge it's
there yet ready like butter okay Dave
want me to peel the ginger Gordon or you
to cut the chilies in half
Charlie lemongrass and shallots I'm
gonna do these ingredients well I'm
going to chop them all we're just gonna
blend up into a paste bung everything in
a blender add turmeric and blades then
add a drizzle of ground oil and blitz
again a little shake and that's your
pace a little smell that in there oh
well get them all nice and off yeah and
watch a little bit in there and start
cooking that out okay now once we start
cooking off this paste then we're
slicing and put the onions in okay so
look at the color of that now no that's
the little magic ingredient in there now
this is what it should be like a weekend
you guys cook you know that yeah yeah
how's it feel to be cooking I'm actually
good really enjoying it really a superb
how they doing those onions sweat them
down nice the sweat done nicely yep see
the way it's all starting to break down
yeah that's ready now for the chicken so
just don't worry about burning in
Littlefinger's all right yeah on there
like that look down
again start sweating the chicken down so
you decide to keep them on the boulevard
rather than you have them on the rebar
going to keep on the bone okay these
active cooking I don't the chicken
drying out coconut milk in please okay
take it van know what then add a tin of
coconut milk followed by some stock
spices and soy sauce now one thing I
haven't seen in here is anything sort of
slightly healthy so the core is gonna be
faced with some green beans all right
okay we're gonna finish it with green
beans but hey you can finish it with
spinach and for broccoli or cauliflower
in there but potatoes in there at the
end but you've got to start eating a
little bit [ __ ] healthier yeah how
could you compare that in your fridge
standing next to that [ __ ] roll of
furry stinky stinky [ __ ] ham I I'm
embarrassed about that I'll be hoping
embarrassed I was embarrassed at the
beginning about that this has made me
even more embarrassed is it good here we
go look at that Oh awesome
amazing it's not number 59 we'll go for
a beer
and that's to help you so if you've
eaten them up quite delicious
for me the most important message is few
guys to pick it up and get you to sit
back in your ways no not at all and
you're gonna have a [ __ ] pot-bellied
bigger than my [ __ ] it's so nice to
see you around the table yeah yeah guys
you do me a favor and stay round the
table
yeah off the [ __ ] telephone ordering
[ __ ] yeah see you see guys Linda is more
often Stan who need fake away well you
got that mmm beautiful